are we rolling
hi everyone I'm Clark Bako McKee
Stanfield we're excited to introduce you
to the new Apple original series The
Changeling how would you describe this
show to a friend it's like a fantasy
horror folklore
in general it's a journey of Two Lovers
doing everything they need to to get
their baby and the gravity of that I
hesitate to describe things yeah just
watch it just turn it on and watch it
watch it let it let it speak to you and
you come up with your own conclusions
y'all smart out there you don't need us
when I got to Brazil there was a lake
there a lagoon they told me not to go
but I didn't listen
to that is
when it falls off my wrist three wishes
will come true with me all your wishes
will come true
have you had any thoughts about hurting
yourself I just need a fun my way back
to myself people call us witches you
know the only real magic Apollo
and the things you'll do for the ones
you love
growing up I've told you this before I
loved sci-fi fantasy but I never really
read them and then would see a movie get
made or TV show made with the
imagination that I had which is someone
who looked like me so one of the big
reasons I loved the changeling was just
reading a story that is fantasy and
horror and beautiful and knowing that
there's people who look like us that are
the heroes yeah I want to see you know
black characters going through these
Journeys yeah but they just happen to be
black but yeah that's the crazy thing
about being black all of us just happen
to be black because it just really is a
human story I just had recently had a
kid when I found out about the story so
I was just like damn I understand that
familial love it's a love unlike any
other but you gotta like experience it
to know it and so you know reading this
character it felt like he lost that and
had to go find that and go through
whatever it takes to get there
I'm so excited for fans because they're
going to be I think pleasantly surprised
by this just beautiful world that we've
been able to create
yeah
really don't think it's one of those
shows where people will guess what's
around the corner ever no like when you
see the show it looks amazing it looks
like a different world that you're being
Zapped into what did you see after you
did what was asked of you you know what
I saw if you don't pay attention there
might be something that you missed
that'll be a key thing to something else
you know I like being excited by things
where I'm like oh I got to pay attention
just to see how one key maybe watches
through another door and we'll see that
in the end
what we do on here is real
Storm is Coming
[Music]
no matter what happens
you're coming with me